[Music]
hello everyone
today we are going to discuss uh
problems again just like in our previous
lecture and the problem that we are
going to consider
is something like this
so again we have a cantilever beam
like that and
and we have a wall here
this beam is attached to this wall
[Music]
and for the load we have
a uniformly distributed load
[Music]
on the top of this beam
we represent it through this set of
arrows
so even though all these arrows are not
perfectly vertical please assume that
they are so
okay now what we say is that
the the magnitude of this uniformly
distributed load
it is given by this w
but please note that w is not newton
rather it is
newton per meter okay
now the question is what is the
deflection at this
free end okay so that's the question
[Music]
what is the deflection at the free end
that is at this
end now uh
if we wish to apply castigliano's
theorem on deflections
we know that we need to have a
a point force at the point where we want
to find out the deflection
but here you note that we only have a
uniformly distributed load there is no
point force acting at this end so what
can we do
so there is a little trick involved here
it is called the
method of fictitious force so since we
do not have a fig
a point force at this end we
artificially introduce a point force
okay so we just introduce
a point force here like this
okay we say its magnitude is p
we do all the processes as if this were
a real
uh point force not an artificially
introduced one
and just at the end we set things back
to as it were
at the beginning as it was in the
beginning by setting this
p equal to zero okay so that's the trick
okay so
uh to introduce a fictitious
uh
point force at the free end
and proceed as usual so
if you want to proceed as usual what
we'll do is we'll take a cut section at
a certain distance
from this free end and we'll say that
we are going to take our origin
here at this free end and take the
x-axis
oriented like this okay so if we just
take the
consider the uh the free body diagram
of that part of the cross section
to the right of the of the to the right
of this cut section
rather so what we'll have is
this thing
where this point force
sorry about that
this point force is very much present
and we also have
this uniformly distributed load
of course only the part
that is under concern all right
and please note that this is still w
of w intensity okay now at the
at this uh exposed section
what we are going to have is
sorry about that
there's a moment and
a shear force okay now
uh what we are going to do is exactly
the same as we had been doing
um in the previous lecture so we wish to
find out
this m okay so this is the m which
appears in
the uh in the formula for uh where we
use
gaussian's theorem of deflections so
this m
uh let's write the equation for it so
this m is in the
clockwise sense and the moment
contributed
by this force p
about an axis which is passing through
this end is
going to be p times x that's the
magnitude
and its sense is in the same sense as
this m so it says
it is plus px
note that this uniformly distributed
load is also going to
exert a moment uh or contribute a moment
when we when we consider its
contributions about an axis
which is also passing through this end
and that will be given
by this expression w
x so w x accounts for the entire force
which is acting and since this is a
uniformly distributed load
we may think of it to be acting
effectively at a distance at the at the
midpoint of this
of this section w x into x by two okay
now i would encourage you to think that
if this were not uniformly distributed
rather
like some arbitrary distributed load
then how could we arrive
uh uh or or what kind of
a method we could use so what we
basically have to do is we have to take
little element uh here uh
i think we discussed uh such a such a
method
back in our course of applied elasticity
nonetheless i would encourage all of you
to think
about what we could do if this were not
uniformly distributed
okay so uh so with this
well we can find out this expression of
m which is just minus p x
minus w x square by two
and uh now we we wish to find out the
deflection
at the free end let that be represented
by this d
d is going to be equal to
[Music]
0 to l and
today we are going to use that
this version of the formula so
so we had discussed this particular form
in the previous lecture
so we basically have del del p of
integration 0 to ln square by
e i and if we take the if we actually
carry out the
differentiation so it becomes that m
square
from that we obtain this m by e i then
del m del p
okay i hope none of you have a problem
with this
so the important thing to note however
in this problem is that this entire
calculation has to be done in such a way
that its value is evaluated
this entire value of the integration it
is evaluated for p equal to zero
okay that must that we must remember so
let us quickly carry out the the
calculation
here so we have for m uh
this minus p x minus w
x squared by 2 divided by
e i and then del m del p
that is nothing but minus x okay so from
this expression
we have this dx 0 to l
and this entire thing let us not forget
must be evaluated at p equal to 0.
so since there is uh some we only have
to do
deal with the algebra here you note that
we might as well set p equal to zero
right away here
so all that will be will be left with is
this
zero to l w
[Music]
x cube by twice
e i d x
so what we're going to end up with is w
l four e to the power four uh divide by
four but
we already have a two here so this is
eight ei
okay so that's the answer that's it
okay so exactly following the method
which you had been using earlier
but only utilizing this this fictitious
point force
we have managed to find out the
deflection even though uh
there was no point force uh to begin
with
okay and this is the method which will
follow all along that uh whenever we are
asked to find out a deflection
or any other entity uh
as we'll see like slope uh
at at a point where uh where the
where the force is not present with the
point force is not present
uh we'll artificially introduce the the
point force uh
and then proceed and then finally we'll
set that artificially introduced point
force to be equal to zero
okay uh all right so
now we go on to the next problem now um
[Music]
so in this problem we are going to
discuss
uh something which is counterpart of the
deflection
as i just mentioned it is the slope so
we are interested in finding out the
slopes
now uh directly in our
statement of the castigliano's theorem
of deflections we have not talked about
slopes about finding the slopes we have
only talked about finding the deflection
at a point where a point force is being
applied ah
in the direction of the point force so
now before going to this problem
let me just uh discuss very very briefly
a corollary to the uh castigliano's
theorem
of deflection okay so this will be
without any proof
uh but i'm sure that many of you who may
have studied
energy methods in their undergraduate
days would be familiar with it with what
i'm going to say
so corollary to castigliano's theorem of
deflection
on deflections
so just like
we have d or
let's say u
[Music]
f bar is equal to del
u dash del f
so this was this was exactly casting you
know serum on deflections
we will have our slope
we have for slope theta
so this theta denotes the slope
okay let me write this as m naught
to represent it to to to to highlight
the fact that this
m naught is actually the uh the applied
external moment okay or an applied
couple
now now as before for hooking materials
we can directly use the strain energy
instead of the complementary energy
okay
and we state all of this without proof
okay
now especially for beam problems
we have this uf bar
[Music]
that is like del del f
of this m square by twice e i
r d x 0 to l we have seen that
and that turns out to be equal to 0 to l
[Music]
m by e i del m del f
dx so just like that
we will have for the slope
so the expression for the strain energy
as it is dependent on the bending on the
flexure
this part so this is the you understand
that this entire thing is the
is a strain energy that doesn't change
okay it is only the
it is only with what uh with respect to
what we are differentiating
that changes when we are when we have to
find out the slope
so so just like before what we'll have
is
this formula
all right so uh let us illustrate this
with an example okay so
in this example what we are going to do
is we are going to use
this thing certainly
but at the same time we are also going
to uh utilize
the uh the concept which we had
introduced with regards to the
fictitious force
uh in the previous problem okay so it
will be in one problem we are going to
apply two different concepts the
concepts
of the fictitious force or equivalent to
the fictitious couple
as well as this this thing ah this slope
formula okay
so the so the problem is like this
we again have a cantilever beam
like that
this is the wall to which it is attached
and this time there is
a point force but it is
acting at a certain distance from this
end
at a certain distance a let's say this
distance is a
from the
so from the right end and the magnitude
here is
p okay
uh let me rewrite that better
okay the question is
what is the rotation of the free end
rotation of the slope of the free end
okay so
so that's our question so
as before we note that at this free end
we certainly don't have a point force
but for the
for the purpose of our rotation or slope
we don't need that
what we actually need is a moment but
that also we don't have
so since we don't have that we
artificially introduce it
let's say we introduce this
this moment m naught with the intention
that after all our calculations are done
we are going to set this m naught equal
to zero
okay so uh
we are going to take this uh again
as before we are going to take a cut
section
okay and we note that
just like before we are going to take
our x-axis
from the right end like this
now we're going to write down the
expression for the moment
so you see there is a certain
algorithmic systematicness
to the way that we proceed with these
problems okay
uh once you do a few problems you'll
also get the hang of it
okay so after you've taken the cut
section we we basically considered this
uh let me do it a little bit more
systematically
we consider this cut section
on the portion of the beam to the right
of this cut section
[Music]
uh
[Music]
sorry about that
okay we have this m naught here
we also have this
this p here
and at this end we need to complete the
free body diagram
by writing this m and this
shear force v okay and now we are going
to write down the expression for the m
so this m uh is in the clockwise sense
and you know that this m naught is also
in the clockwise sense
so they have the same sign
or the contribution of this p ah
towards the moment about an axis
calculated the bottom axis which is
passing through this
end we note that uh we have to use
the heavy side of the step function here
okay
so uh it's like this
that the moment arm is given by x minus
a
because you understand that this entire
thing so this
this entire portion is x here
okay uh this part is a
so the moment arm is given by x minus a
this distance
but that gets activated only when you
are at a distance
x which is greater than a and that fact
is captured
by writing this or multiplying this term
with this heavy side okay so this entire
thing is equal to zero
uh now yesterday uh or sorry i've
actually recorded the previous video
yesterday so i said yesterday but in the
previous video
uh we had
proceeded uh after writing something
like this
using the macaulay bracket and then
going to symbolic python to do our
calculations
uh but you see uh for simple enough
situations we can actually proceed by
hand
uh which is what i'm going to show here
okay so
just to make the thing nice and explicit
we write the actual expression for m
okay so this thing
so this h is the heavy side okay
now we wish to find out the slope
okay
so for that we use the formula which we
had written in the previous page
now this
m is this entire thing that we can write
this e i remains as it is now for the
del m del
uh m naught you note that it is only
this term which is going to contribute
okay so that's actually good news for us
because it makes the expression very
simple all right
now you note that this integration
actually goes from 0 to l so it is going
from this part
to app to this end but
due to the presence of this heavy side
we need to
to uh to break this uh integration
term by term uh that will actually make
our life
a bit easier so for the first one
uh okay
and please note that this entire thing
has to be calculated
at m naught equal to zero okay similarly
here this entire thing has to be
evaluated
at m not equal to zero now
before going into the next step let me
just note that
uh within this entire integrand
you see i am very much free to
immediately set before going into the
next step
this m not equal to 0 so that will make
uh
make the calculation much easier so
what i'll do is i'll do this
multiplication with this minus 1
so i'll have this p into x minus
a but now uh i'll
already activate this heavy side so that
this integration from 0 to l actually
gets converted
from a to l because whatever was from 0
to a
that becomes 0 because h
or the heavy side of x minus a as long
as x is less than a
that is equal to 0. okay
so now now it's quite simple enough
all they have to do is finish up our
our integration here so this is a to l
ah this is uh actually i can do the
and carry out the integrations
so this becomes
x square by 2 minus
ax putting the limits of
integration okay
so i'll skip a couple of steps here and
write the
the final form here this is
p by twice e i
so so please note that i
actually know this answer which which is
why i'm able to write it down in one
shot
i have not actually uh done the
the intermediate steps uh in my head
okay so please do not overestimate
my abilities on that regard uh
all these things i i always do step by
step but just here in
in the interest of time i'm skipping
ahead all right so this is our
our answer and you know that if you have
the special case of
a is equal to l by 2 you'll get some
some familiar formulas which you may
have come across during your gate
preparation
okay so on that note we have learned two
important concepts here
uh one regarding the the introduction of
fictitious forces or couples
and other regarding the the use of the
uh of the corollary to carcinogen
deflections
uh such as to say that it is something
like the castigliano's theorem on slopes
using the moment okay so on that note
i'll end this lecture and we'll continue
with problems in our next
lecture thank you very much